[Música]
65.000 detenidos en una inédita guerra
contra Las pandillas en El Salvador
liderada por el presidente nayib bukele
denuncias sobre violaciones a los
Derechos Humanos
señalamientos de un avance hacia el
autoritarismo en el país y una política
de seguridad que le ha permitido gozar
de índices récord de popularidad al
mandatario El Salvador ha pasado de ser
el país más peligroso del mundo
literalmente el país más peligroso del
mundo
a estar en camino a ser el país más
seguro de América en este en cinco
minutos abordamos la guerra a las
pandillas que Libra bukele en el país y
explicamos Por qué sus actos que algunos
aplauden y otros rechazan generan
tantísima polémica por décadas pandillas
como la Mara Salvatrucha o barrio 18
sembraron el terror en El Salvador con
índices de homicidios récord extorsiones
y desplazamientos forzados generalizados
los gobiernos salvadoreños com batieron
a las maras por décadas algunos incluso
fueron señalados de pactar beneficios
con estos grupos a cambio de disminuir
la violencia es con la promesa de acabar
con esta espiral de violencia y dar
seguridad que buque le llegó al poder en
2019 rechazando cualquier pacto con las
maras
tras una relativa calma entre el 24 y el
27 de marzo de 2022 93 personas fueron
asesinadas en El Salvador Esto fue el
detonante para que ese mismo 27 de marzo
la asamblea legislativa aprobara un
estado de excepción que ha permitido la
detención de miles de ciudadanos el
gobierno ha desplegado miles de agentes
en operativos sorpresa a poblaciones
enteras Y encarcelado acerca del 65.000
ciudadanos que el gobierno señala de
pertenecer a las bandas criminales
según datos oficiales en 2015 el país
registró un máximo de 103 asesinatos por
cada 100.000 habitantes en 2019 cuando
buque le llegó al poder el país bajó a
una tasa de 36 homicidios por cada
100.000 habitantes y en 2022 la cifra
cayó a 7,8 asesinatos y recientemente en
febrero pasado bukele celebró que el
país llevara 300 días sin contabilizar
homicidios dijo que su política ha hecho
del país el más seguro de América Latina
de acuerdo a una encuesta de la
consultora galupe publicada en febrero
el 92% de los salvadoreños Si considera
que la seguridad ha mejorado esto le ha
supuesto también un aumento de
popularidad al mandatario con un 90% en
febrero según galu también en América
Latina donde en enero de este 2023 tuvo
una opinión favorable del 92%. pero el
estado de excepción anula varios
derechos constitucionales como la
libertad de asociación y reunión hacer
informado el motivo de la detención y la
restricción de la asistencia de un
abogado varias ong denuncian violaciones
a los derechos humanos
y la organización Cristóbal resaltan
detenciones arbitrarias sin juicio real
desapariciones forzadas tortura entre
otros además indican que para diciembre
de 2022 al menos 1600 detenidos eran
menores de edad también denuncian
muertes bajo custodia y según human
right watch el estado de excepción
afecta principalmente a poblaciones
históricamente en empobrecidas otra de
las mayores críticas a las detenciones
masivas y sin garantías es que existe
entre los detenidos un número
indeterminado de inocentes la Corte
Suprema no ha resuelto 3.500 habeas
Corpus de ciudadanos que han solicitado
que se revise si su detención fue o no
legal y decenas de familias han llevado
casos a la Corte Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos el gobierno por su
parte ha liberado a 3.000 detenidos pero
sin procesos judiciales transparentes es
imposible determinar Quién es culpable y
quién no el portal independiente del
faro publicó un informe con audios
facilitados presuntamente por la Mara
Salvatrucha indicando que la banda
habría pactado con el gobierno disminuir
los homicidios en la publicación en la
banda criminal se atribuye a haber
asesinado a 87 personas en el fatídico
fin de semana previo a la aprobación del
estado de excepción esto luego de que el
gobierno de bukele hubiera roto el
presunto pacto con las bandas que él
niega la cadena británica vivís y
publicó audios facilitados por barrio 18
sureños en los que sus integrantes
afirman haber negociado también con el
gobierno además el gobierno de Estados
Unidos ha acusado a funcionarios
salvadoreños de negociar con las
pandillas bukele rechaza a esos
señalamientos y acusa a las ongs y a los
grandes medios de tener intereses
invertidos en perpetuar la violencia
en medio de las críticas preocupa la
consolidación del gobierno en torno a
bukele en la actualidad su partido
nuevas ideas domina dos tercios de la
asamblea legislativa en 2021 el congreso
destituyó a los jueces de la sala de lo
constitucional el principal órgano
judicial del país también destituyó al
fiscal general que investigaba la
corrupción en el gobierno finalmente el
año pasado la asamblea también votó para
cambiar la Constitución y permitió que
el presidente pueda ser reelegido
inicialmente el estado de excepción
debía durar solamente 30 días y ha sido
prorrogado mes tras mes a un año esta
medida está en manos de un mandatario
que no parece querer dejar el poder
pronto
además observadores de Derechos Humanos
como el Instituto afari internacional y
han advertido que la guerra de bukele
contra las pandillas podría ser
contraproducente a largo plazo si no se
atacan la pobreza y la falta de
oportunidades que son las principales
causas de la violencia en el país Qué
piensan ustedes respecto a esta polémica
política de seguridad los invitamos a
compartir sus opiniones en nuestras
redes sociales y los esperamos con más
episodios de cinco minutos en France 24
y France 24.com